Speaking of police, it's spreading from Portland.
I almost would say like a virus.
Plain clothes police officers threw a protester
into an unmarked van in New York City yesterday.
The video is being widely shared on social
media.
Millions and millions upon millions of views.
And once again, we get to this question of
what is the line between legal policing by
undercover officers with undercover cars vs.
the authoritarian suppression of protesters
appearing to be denied due process.
Now, the police department says this is a
simple arrest.
A woman was allegedly damaging police cameras.
Police came in, arrested her.
Open and shut.
It's all very, very simple.
Now, it is true that NYPD will often use unmarked
vehicles when they're looking for people with
warrants.
The idea is you want to show up in something
that's not obviously a police car.
If you have a dangerous suspected criminal,
they may act radically or try to flee if they
see a police car.
So you show up with some kind of unmarked
vehicle.
Now, the counter in this particular case from
legal advocates and from other groups is that
this is the worst possible time to be using
these unmarked vans and that this was not
someone police had been looking for for a
long time who had prior warrants.
This was something that supposedly happened
during these protests, alleged damage to police
cameras and thus using these unmarked warrants,
squad vans is completely out of scope unless
you're trying to send a message and intimidate.
Now, there are about four, five different
issues here.
The first issue is the growing use of these
squads that drive up to a protest.
Guys run out with guns and throw someone into
the van.
You may not even know whether these are police
or whether you're being kidnaped.
And then they drive away.
Extremely dystopian, extremely disturbing
and concerning.
There's the bigger discussion about reforming
police.
We had a number of segments about that this
week already.
We had another one 10 minutes ago and we're
going to continue talking about that.
Then there's the political utility of the
repression of protests for Donald Trump.
And we can't ignore that.
And we can discuss these things separately.
NYPD policy, federal troops versus local law
enforcement.
We can have all these discussions separately.
But under underneath all of this, there's
this idea that a desperate, cornered Trump
wants to foment chaos, incite more incidents
to then justify more deployment of militarized
troops, to create more chaos and more unrest,
to justify needing an authoritarian president
to protect you from the chaos that you yourself
caused and fomented.
There's this vicious circle feedback loop.
And while here we're talking about NYPD rather
than federal paramilitaries that have been
dispatched, the strategic implications and
the implications politically are very, very
similar.
But there's another issue that we have to
talk about.
One of the things that's coming up in these
incidents with unmarked vans is people resisting
arrest.
Now, resisting arrest is an old trope.
I've been telling you for years that resisting
arrest can be a very pernicious catchall that's
used to justify using more force against people
to retroactively justify police interactions
where it doesn't even make sense because you
can only start to resist arrest after an interaction
has started using resisting arrest as a justification
after the fact doesn't make any sense, but
it's extra relevant right now.
There are many normal, reasonable people who,
if you're at a protest at an unmarked police
vehicle, drives up, which I'm already using
the wrong terms.
You don't know that it's a police vehicle.
If a vehicle dries up that has no indication
of being a police vehicle and dudes without
law enforcement uniforms jump out and go after
you.
You don't yet have any reason to believe that
that's the police.
You could genuinely think you're about to
be kidnaped by random people.
So then you try to get away or at least delay
being taken until you can figure out what's
going on.
Now, you're resisting arrest and that's used
to justify being manhandled and even more
force used against you.
It's a joke.
I mean, it's it's truly a dystopian joke.
The people defending this or at least looking
the other way and saying, well, it's sort
of kind of makes sense.
If the woman was suspected of destroying cameras,
you've lost the plot.
How does it become the norm that this is how
you're taken away for the alleged crime of.
Damaging a camera.
OK, this is not some major violent individual,
even allegedly.
It's not someone wanted for beating their
wife for what?
You know, whatever.
Imagine whatever violent crime you want to
get, you know, raping someone you're suspected
of damaging a camera.
And we're now saying it's an acceptable response
for an unmarked van to drive up as if they're
looking for whoever slam on its brakes.
Six guys run out and throw you into the van.
Now, I hope it doesn't happen, but imagine
that if one of these.
Out of uniform officers in an unmarked van
gets killed because someone believes they're
getting kidnaped, then what?
Well, then it will become a catalyst for even
more repression of protests.
You can be sure of that.
But this is very ugly.
Four, four, five, six different reasons.
And because it is so useful politically, this
you know, even though these weren't federal
troops, this still serves Trump's political
motivation, which is where for law and order,
he keeps tweeting every 12 hours.
Trump tweets Law and order.
It still foments the idea that we need an
armed and aggressive police to keep order
in cities.
And it's useful for Donald Trump.
Either way.
So let me know what you think.
Is my analysis missing something important
here?
Am I overstating the concerning nature of
this?
Let me know.
I'm on Twitter and remember that you can get
the daily audio podcast every day weekdays.
We take weekends off on whatever your favorite
podcast platform is.
I tune Stitcher, Spotify, Pandora.
You choose.
But we are on all of them.
And we'll take
a quick break and
be back after this.